Hey, everybody.
I'm Andrew Brogdon, and welcome
back to the Mobile Ads Garage,
where we cover mobile
ads code the way
I enjoy cheese
burgers-- thoroughly.
In our last episode, we covered
how to import the Google Mobile
Ads SDK into your projects.
Today, with the help of my
partner, Gary the Graphics Guy,
I'm going to build on that
by talking about banner ads.
To start, let's imagine
that I'm in an application.
[TONE]
Perfect.
One of the simplest
ways to monetize an app
is just by adding a banner.
Here we go.
Now, there's a lot you
can do with banners.
You can use different sizes.
You can put them in
different places.
And you can even animate them.
But we'll keep it
simple for now.
Let's start with Android
Studio and a simple banner
across the bottom of the screen.
So here's my app
in Android Studio.
It's just a simple
Hello World, and I'm
going to add a banner
ad right at the bottom.
And here are the steps involved.
So first, I'll place
an AdView in my layout,
then I'll build
a request object,
and then I'll load an ad.
So here's my layout file,
and I'm going to drop in
and AdView element.
There we go.
And you can see Android
Studio pointing out
that I need a new namespace
reference, because of the ads
attributes, and I'll
accept that, no problem.
There we go.
Now, let's talk real quick
about what's in here.
So I've got the AdView
element right there.
I've got my width and
height set to Wrap Content,
which is what you want.
I've got some positioning
code, and then I
have two attributes
that I really
want to draw your attention to.
Ad size, right
here, tells the SDK
what size ad you want
to load-- banner, medium
rectangle, that sort of thing.
And then add unit ID
tells the SDK which
ad unit corresponds to this
banner placement in the ad.
Ad units are created
at apps.admob.com,
and generally you want
a unique ad unit ID
for each of the spots in your
app where an AdView appears.
That way you can control things
like mediation and refresh rate
and so on independently.
Now I can go into
my activity code
and find a reference to
that AdView object that
just dropped in the layout
file by using Find View By ID.
There we go.
Perfect.
All right.
So step 1 done.
Now I'll move on to
building a request.
So the SDK has a builder
class for ad requests
that makes it really
easy to construct them.
So I'll make a new one here
and call its build method.
We're going to into a lot
more detail on ad requests
and how they work
in another video.
But for right now, just remember
that every time you load an ad,
you'll need a fresh ad
request object to do it.
Now, one thing I am going to
do is add a test device ID
to this request by
adding a function called
Just Before Build and
giving it the emulators ID.
This way I can be sure I'll
get test ads while I'm testing,
and that's important.
Always, always use
test ads to test.
OK, that's all we need here
to build my ad request.
So what's left?
Just making the actual
call to load an ad.
And since I have
my request object,
I just need to call
AdView's Load Add Method,
and I'm ready to go.
Excellent.
All right.
Let's run this bad boy.
And there's my test banner.
Excellent.
So I placed an AdView, I built
a request, and loaded an ad.
Job done.
Great.
Now that we've got Android
down, let's move on to iOS
and, remember, it's like
making a tarte tatin instead
of an apple pie.
Same concepts,
different language.
Oh.
Fine, Gary.
It's like CK Ogden's
seminal translation
of Wittgenstein's Tractatus.
Same concepts,
different language.
You don't know me.
Now, on to Xcode.
All right.
So here we are in Xcode, and
I've got my sample app going.
And I'd like a banner
across the bottom.
So how can I do that?
Well, here are the steps
for showing a banner in iOS.
If you just got done
watching the Android section,
these should seem very familiar.
First, I'm going to place a
GADBannerView on my storyboard.
Then I'm going to build
a new request object.
And then I load an ad.
So here's my storyboard,
and I'm just going
to drop a generic view onto it.
Let me drag that over.
And then I'll use the Identity
Inspector to change the class
to get GADBannerView.
There we go.
And now I'll throw some
constraints on my banner.
I'd like it to be at the
bottom of the screen, centered.
And the size is going
to be 320 by 50, which
is our standard banner size.
There we go.
Add the constraints.
Let's see how that looks.
Cool.
Now, I need to get a
reference in my code.
I'm going to use
Counterparts and just
drag it over to
the View Controller
and make a property
called BannerView.
Excellent.
And you can see
Xcode complaining
that I'm missing an import.
So let me go ahead and add
one in for Google Mobile Ads.
The SDK is distributed
as a framework
to make that part easy.
Now I just need to give
my banner an ad unit.
These are made at
apps.admob.com, and generally
for every place in your
app that you show an ad,
you'll need a
different ad unit ID
so you can control things like
refresh rate and mediation
independently.
And last thing, I just
need to give the banner
a reference to the Root
View Controller, which
my sample app is this one.
So GADBannerView is placed.
Now I need a request object.
Requests are represented
by the GAD Request Class
in iOS, which has a static
request method to build them.
There's a lot you
can do with requests,
which were going to cover in
one of our subsequent videos.
For now, just remember that
each time you load an ad,
you'll need to build a fresh
request object to do it.
And I'm going to go ahead and
add the simulator to the list
of test devices on my request.
That way I can be sure I'll
get a test ad in response
to it, which is important.
You should always, always use
test ads when you're testing.
They prevent false impressions
and false click-throughs,
both of which are bad things.
So the only thing left
to do now is load an ad.
To do that, I just need to
call the GADBannerView's Load
Request Method and pass
it my ad request object.
Excellent.
So that's the last step.
Let me run the app,
see what happens.
And there's my test banner.
All right.
So here are the
steps one more time.
To get a banner working, you
just place a GADBannerView,
build a request,
and then load an ad.
Job done.
Banner adds are a great way
to get started monetizing,
but there's a lot
more to talk about.
Where's the best
place to put them?
How can you avoid
unintended click-throughs?
We'll cover all that and
more in our next episode.
In the meantime, I've
got some great resources
to link you to like our AdMob
Interstitial Guides for iOS
and Android, which have
notes for Java, Objective-C,
and Swift.
We also have sample
code up on GitHub
for both operating systems.
So check those out
if you're interested.
You might also like
AdMob's no-nonsense guide
to ad monetization.
It's an overview of
monetization strategies
that includes code and
tips from other engineers.
As always, if you've got a
technical question relating
to anything you've just seen,
stop by our support forum.
And if you've got a question
about this video series
or an idea for something
you'd like us to cover,
leave a comment below, and Gary
and I will see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]